well let's do some speed running we are
11 12.
climbing up this is the third
the third speed run
and uh just to remind everybody we're
playing
fundamental openings we're playing e4 e5
d4 d5 and with white we're playing e4
repertoire but very
very basic openings to emphasize
to emphasize fundamentals
[Music]
okay
let's begin
let's go e4
all right so g6 uh this is the first
time that we are encountering this move
in the speed run
we've encountered it many times before
and of course as you guys know
first we need to play d4
maybe i should have bishop h16
uh and and in this situation there's
there's many many setups that you can
adopt many setups that you can adopt
with white but i'm going to teach you
guys one that i like to play in blitz
and it's quite annoying to face because
people who play the modern generally are
looking for a pretty tactical game
and knight c3 will often lead to those
kinds of positions
but you can play an interesting move
here you can play the move c3 with the
pawn
and this creates
essentially a pawn chain
so that the bishop is biting on granite
and the downside of this move
is that it deprives the knight of the c3
square but as i often say that's not a
problem later on the knight can develop
to d2
and just like in the london when you
build a little pawn house you want to
put the bishop
in in that hole bishop d3
and now you develop normally and so the
only real point of this is that black's
bishop is essentially harmless for the
time being
yeah we can play knight f3 first it
doesn't doesn't really matter bishop d3
knight f3
don't put too much weight into like
which particular developing movement as
long as you try not to develop this
knight until the dark squared bishop is
out
if possible that's not always possible
and there's ways of dealing with it if
you have to play knight t2 first
okay so he goes d5
um so we have to determine whether e5 is
good for us and i think it is
there's a couple of reasons for that
he's weakened all these dark squares
and closing up the center is going to
give us an easier job of of exploiting
them so to me e5 is basically a
no-brainer here he can play this like in
a french you can play c5 but then we're
just gonna go knight f3
okay so knight f3 let's continue
developing
and c5 so he does end up going c5 now we
don't need to react to that move we can
play d take c5 that's a possibility and
try to cling to the extra pawn but i
don't really think that's in the spirit
of the position i think we should just
continue developing we don't have to
worry about the pressure on the d4 pawn
it's not reached any kind of
dangerous levels just yet okay so c4 i
think helps us a lot
he continues to lock up the center and
what's going to eventually happen is
that we're going to have
basically a blank check to attack on the
king side and why do i say we're going
to attack on the king side largely
because he's got these massive
weaknesses
on the dark squares which eventually
we're going to try to occupy with
possibly this night
who can tell me what maneuver is
necessary in order to get the b1 knight
in a position where it can ultimately
try to exploit uh the the the f6 square
and i propose that we start with a move
that may seem mysterious it looks
actually quite bad
which is rookie one and a lot of you
guys are finding it and the point is to
vacate the f1 square for the night what
we're going to do is go knight bd2
knight f1 and then either knight e3
knight g4
or even knight g3 with a potential
sacrifice on h5
which sometimes happens if you think
about this bishop you can kind of put
together
the dots
and we also could play bishop g5 but
that's not mandatory we're not worried
about him pushing his f pawn so let's
just continue with the general plan
knight f1
knight e3 knight g4 and then we're going
to try to put that knight on f6
okay so a little
spanner in the works goes knight f5
which is a good move now we can take
that knight but i don't really like that
idea why give up this bishop we can go
g4 to kick the knight away
but
i'll show this after the game there's
the move knight h4 in those kinds of
positions which is quite nasty
um
so bishop g5 feels very natural here
because we're exploiting the drawback of
knight f5 we're hitting the queen with
tempo and we're still clamping down on
the f6 square
and now the move g4 becomes
more possible although if we put a pawn
on g4 we take away that square from the
knight so let's see where he puts his
queen and then we'll decide okay goes f6
and this basically does our work for us
because when this move is played in the
wrong types of positions
what's going to happen at the end of the
day is that this e5 square is going to
be a huge huge weakness for black
and our job is to occupy that square
preferably with a knight but not
immediately if we go 95 immediately he
takes it and then the knight has to be
replaced to the rook and the rook's not
the best blockader
so we can take different approaches in
this position
my favorite approach is to start by
trading off black's only active piece
which is the f5 knight but not with a
bishop i still like this bishop i want
to give it away
so what move am i thinking of which is
still in accordance with our general
plan
which is still in accordance with the
general point we can also play queen d2
here very flexible move knight e3 or
knight g3 i like knight e3 because we're
also aiming for g4 once again
and if black ignores us we can play
knight g495 which is exactly what's
going to happen knight g4 this is not
worrisome the pawn on c3 is safe
and another thing to remember when
you've got this kind of situation with
full control over a square you don't
need to rush
i see this very often you don't need to
rush to put a piece there right there's
no nobody's going to do anything with
that e5 square so what i like is a more
flexible player so let's connect the
rooks first
and maybe on the next move we'll put a
knight on e5 but sometimes the threat is
stronger than the execution here
so we connect our rooks maybe we'll
double on the e file
and such positions are generally not
you can't win them very fast you have to
be very patient okay so he's basically
forcing us to go 95.
uh i will oblige
and of course we take on e5 with the
knight
yeah this pawn is like in general
black's pawn structure is just horrific
we can also put a queen on g5
okay but in general i propose a slow
approach here where we improve our
position methodically and slowly and not
you know we don't do anything drastic
even queen g5 i don't like as much
because black can go queen f6 in
response
and offer a queen trade and i i want to
keep the queens on the board in this
position so
what's the go-to plan
when uh
in such positions is is to double the
rooks on the e-file but
before we even do that there is a
potentially worrisome source of counter
play which is the move g5
um
but it doesn't really work and if he
goes g5 i'll show you guys why
in general if you're playing these kinds
of positions with black
you have to try to get some form of
activity whether it's on the king side
or
in the center i mean if you just sit
around passively and let your opponent
destroy you
you're not going to last very long
okay so in this position i think it's a
great idea to prevent g5 why is g5
dangerous because
if we let black unfold his pieces on the
king's side you know you can go g5 h4
and then this bishop from e8 can
activate on h5 so why allow
the ex king side expansion so the move
that comes to mind is either h or f4
but f4 is a little bit weakening f4
cuts off the diagonal for the queen so
let's go h4 and then we can go g3 you
often see this pawn arrangement on the
king side knight g4
and general as i said
uh we want to keep a knight on e5 so
generally speaking a trade wouldn't be
good but if you just look at this
position concretely you can see that
we're just transforming our advantage
our knight did its job on e5 now we take
on g4 and we can simply take this pawn
on e6
and now we are we're up upon and we
still have
this monster e5 square
and bishop d7 and this will often happen
just total collapse
don't automatically move your rook back
just
marinate on this position for a second
don't forget about your bishop on c2
there's a reason we kept it on the board
there's a reason we kept it on the board
and the reason is rook takes g6 and he
resigns
before we get a chance to play it
okay that was a nice positional game
simple but
but nice
okay
time for some analysis
so yeah this is called the modern the
modern defense it's closely related to
the perk
which is e4 d6 and these openings often
transpose into each other and the perk
black plays knight f6 and then g6 so in
the modern black delays the development
oops black delays the development of
the g8 knight
for
many reasons sometimes then i goes to e7
as it did here
um and sometimes black waits for the
most opportune moment to go knight f6
so d4 bishop g7 now the move c3 which is
far from the most popular and most
people develop one of the knights here
knight c3 and knight f3 and in previous
speed runs we've played knight c3 which
is sort of the classical approach i like
knight c3 more than knight f3 uh because
this allows you to play the austrian
attack and the austrian attack is the
move f4
often considered sort of the most
principled way of meeting the perk of
the mod not necessarily the best but the
most ambitious
and you can also play f3 in these
positions and go for an english attack
setup with bishop e3
and in a sense we're doing the same
thing on the other side of the board
which is of course a lot more positional
we go c3
uh blunting the bishop
and and then bishop d3 so generally of
course black does not play e6 black
plays d6 and gets into a perk
and i play this line very frequently in
in over the board blitz against strong
opponents thank you curious for the five
gifted godakamsky is also well known for
liking the setup with white and
basically this bishop goes to g5 then
the knight goes to d2 and you're playing
against the g7 bishop if black is
accurate
are you curious again if black is
accurate
this is not the most dangerous system
but it's easy to play and it's easy to
understand
um he plays z6 which is like i don't
remember what what is the setup called
is that the hippo when black goes like
97 97 and then double fiance i never
remember what it's called
i think it's the hippo yeah
so the hippo can be good against certain
setups but
here our opponent played some weird
mixture of the hippo in the french which
is no good d5 is a mistake strategically
yeah i mean if you can trade dark
squared bishops that would be awesome
because it would oftentimes expose even
further expose the weakness of the dark
squares
if black wants to play a hippo then you
should go d6 and then b6
bishop b7 and it's not so bad it's not
so easy to crack the hippo
um
it's a highly underrated
opening in fact against many different
setups if white plays the right setup
the hippo i think can be shattered
pretty quickly
but not not necessarily the way that
i've played it
okay so d5 i hope e5 made sense of
course we don't want to trade on d5 here
that just
solves all of black's problems thank you
for the thousand bits yes i will
um 97 now we play knight f3
a lot of people in this type of position
make a
a move that i don't really like as much
which is f4 this looks good right you're
building up your center first of all
this is unnecessary it's not like e5 the
five pawn is a weakness that needs to be
defended second of all you're making it
harder for yourself to exploit the dark
squared weaknesses now your bishop can't
come out
and you know you occupy real estate on
the king side it's going to make it
harder for you to maneuver
so
f4 is is good in positions where you
have a realistic shot at playing f5
but here you obviously don't because
black is defending this with like 800
pieces
uh so i think knight f3 is just more
more reasonable okay so c5
castles and and c4 is a
i think another inaccuracy black should
probably keep some tension going on the
square
to at least uh
to at least divide our attention because
the way he played it we
we can just divert all of our attention
to the king side
okay
so castles
and now again rookie one the whole point
is to open up this pathway for the night
and you might be asking well i've talked
before about the three move role and how
to evaluate whether ideas are realistic
remember that this is a highly closed
center so
you have a lot more time the atoms in
the position move a lot more slowly
so
you can think of the temperature as
being pretty low here um and so you have
a lot of time to to move your pieces
around from side to side
all right so knight bc6 and now we start
the maneuver
basically the three move rule says well
it's not a formal rule but
if you have an open a position with an
open or semi-open center
if an idea takes three moves or longer
it's likely unrealistic like that's all
that it is
um and it's it's got a lot of exceptions
okay
what should black play if not for f6
well black should probably play for
queen side pressure b5 before
i i honestly think black is
strategically in huge trouble
uh so he's already made a lot of
mistakes
um what about h4 instead of castles asks
dave h four instead h4 is an interesting
approach but it kind of burns the
bridges
because now if you want to castle king
side it's not as appetizing yeah in some
of these positions h4 is good but black
can go h6
and create these these annoying pawns
where if you go h5 then black goes g5
uh but i'll tell you when h4 is good if
if the f pawn can move to f4 then
sometimes h4 can be good
but for example
in this position i would
consider h4 more heavily because if
black plays h6 there's this typical idea
of going h5
creating a weakness on g5 and now
hitting it with f4
this is an example of when f4 actually
impacts the position and you start
opening up black's king side so this
would be an interesting approach if we
played knight f3 then it doesn't make as
much sense
okay so knight f1 knight f5
now we get our bishop out with tempo and
f6 is maybe even the decisive mistake
i would say that
black has to keep
i mean
black has to refrain from that move and
play like queen b6
but again this is really bad we would go
queen c1
yeah you can go h4
you can move the h-bond but not in order
to attack but in order to go knight h2
knight g4 and knight f6 that is another
pathway to the f6 square
that is another pathway to the f6 square
so
[Music]
black is strategically busted here
there's very little the black can do
very little little the black can do
against
kind of dark square infiltration
um
yeah i'm at a loss to say
what black can even play here maybe the
lesser evil is to go queen c7 and try to
go b5 b4 but that doesn't even give
black anything
okay so f6 takes takes bishop f6 queen
f6 and now knight e3
our main
advantage of course is this e5 square
more broadly the fact that black has a
terrible bishop
a terrible pawn on e6 and we have
massive pressure down the e file
um b5
knight g4 well like i explained f6 was a
mistake because it increases the
accessibility to
this weak square it also basically
prevents black from ever having any
counterplay because black is never going
to be able to go e5
um
and as long as that's the case
you're basically sitting on black's
position permanently
okay queen d2
h5 creates even more weaknesses although
again the position's already hopeless
strategically
and now very patiently just doubling
rooks on the e-file
yeah white also has zero risk of losing
this position thank you aiden parker for
the five gifted subs
um
i mentioned earlier that
we weren't afraid of the move g5
who can find a strong response for white
in this position
yeah i mean you can play rookie one but
that that doesn't really uh prevent
black from continuing to expand yeah
knight f3 i think is a very strong move
here
it's a very hard move to find for
multiple reasons it's a night move
backwards which is already
one of the most difficult moves in chess
it also moves the knight away from the
outpost but here we're simply going
after black spawns we're attacking g5
we're attacking e6
and if black plays g4
then you go knight g5 and the e6 bond
cannot be defended and black's hole
position collapses
and this leads me to an important point
which is that if you have
a piece on an outpost don't assume that
it has to stay there for all of eternity
the important thing isn't that we have a
knight on e5 it's that we have control
of the square
that's also why in isolated queen pawn
positions
i always try to emphasize it's less
important to put a piece on the
blockading square in front of the pawn
but
much more important rather to have full
control of that square so you don't have
to worry about
uh your opponent playing e5 and freeing
himself up does rook f5 defend the epon
yeah i mean you can play rook f6 but
then you'll lose the g pawn
but once he played sorry once he played
uh
knight h6 now g5 is more of a well it's
still not really a threat but i was just
this was giving me a headache so we now
have a possibility of just stopping
everything
so knight g4 and of course
again we are flexible in regards to
trading knights because we win the pawn
more resilient would have been bishop f7
but then we would have just parked the
rook on e5 h5 is now a threat and the
position is lost
yeah this isn't just about upon black
soul position falls apart instantly as
soon as the flood gates open and black's
position is just so riddled with
weaknesses it's impossible to hold um
g5 is not such a big threat again
don't think of things just as threats or
not threats right when i say a move is
unpleasant it doesn't mean because oh
you're going to lose your queen on the
next one
g5 and h4 opens up some space on the
king side and especially as i mentioned
that this bishop can come alive through
h5 that gives black unnecessary counter
play and if possible you want to prevent
these things what was the critical
mistake for black
there wasn't one there were several i
mean already d5 is a mistake
then c4 is a mistake because it takes
the pressure off of the d4 pawn
and then f6 might be the decisive
mistake
[Music]